i'm connor jessup and i play tyler locke
i'm darby stansfield and i play nina
lock hi i am connor jessup's friend
griffin gluck and i play gabe on the
show
friend acquaintance distant acquaintance
for eight months and i played gabe on
lock and key hi my name is helea jones
and i play eden hawkins and today we are
going to play a buzzfeed questionnaire
to see what character from lock and key
we are
okay so the first question in this quiz
is how would your friends describe you
charming
introverted adventurous ambitious
loyal or extroverted i'm gonna regret
this later but i really do think
charming is the one that describes you
grev yeah i thought you have to say that
too that was the video that you did for
me
definitely charming i am so flattered
right now thank you i think i'm going to
be boring i think is loyal i think
you're loyal i'm very i think that's
totally true connor you're either you're
somehow a mix between introverted and
adventurous oh your adventure expand on
that
you're in greece
no
i would say that you're adventurous i
agree that's what i would say
yes
i'd say you're adventurous
or extroverted i would like to be more
adventurous like well you think about
like what you did your hair after we
wrapped and the you know what that you
got on the back of your
yes that's the cave
yeah dyeing my hair blue and tattooing a
keyhole on the back of my neck very
adventurous things i wish it was more
like going to greece or something but
like
i'll take it i'll take it second
question which school subject is your
favorite you can choose from
math
science english
art
and foreign language okay this is easy
math is hard science is hard english is
my first language so all right fun
history boring art
easy cop-out everyone loves art foreign
language i did go to a french school but
all my french teachers were really mean
so
your answer is your answer is none of
the abode
my answer is the easy cop-out art yeah
it's also it's also the one that's
biggest so
done easy
got involved english is the true answer
english was my friend wait a minute did
you just use that no i said i really
liked science until math got involved
mine would be art the third question is
choose a comic book to movie adaptation
that you love and the options are dark
knight black panther scott pilgrim vs
the world wonder woman avengers end game
and kingsman the secret service i did
not know kingsman and the secret service
was actually a comic book conversation
but i love that movie i just watched
wonder movement woman i kid you not last
night that's how you're spending your
nights in italy hey i had a i had a
train ride man i had a train ride okay
this is enough they're all good all
those movies i mean i'm going to choose
the dark knight only because i'm miss
heath ledger oh my god i was about to
say
his joker is just the best joker sorry
joaquin best joker so that's where i'm
going i'm gonna go scott pilgrim just
because it's the most uh it's the most
fun one me too scott pilgrim like
locking key was shot in toronto yeah
fun fact yeah wow hashtag fun fact i
think for me it's between black panther
and kingsman yeah a little bit a little
torn there go with candy that was your
first impulse but i didn't know that was
a comic book adaptation so for that fact
i'm gonna go black panther yeah yeah i'm
not listening to any of you you're all
you know you're not trying to lead me
astray the next question is now which
key from lock and key would you like to
have mirror key ghost key anywhere key
headphone
echo key or the identity key it's so
obvious but the anywhere key is
definitely the best one right but you're
already in another country you don't get
to choose that key uh yeah but he
doesn't want to take that long i don't
want to have to fly home yeah exactly
also then griffin could run out of
excuses to come visit jesus that's true
you could just open up the door the
anywhere key and the head key because i
love the concept of the head key because
you can just and that's why i got a
tattoo of the keyhole because i love the
idea of being able to explore your mind
and expand your mind and relive do you
really want to see what the inside of
your head looks like i mean like that's
i'm going to expand my mind by choosing
the anywhere key
yes
yeah i think the anywhere key is more
practical yes
me too what about you griff i was just
thinking as i read this that um if i had
the identity key i could live like a
hannah montana you know secret life of
hannah montana fantasy um and just be
someone else
all she does is put on a wig griffin you
don't it's not like i really want to see
you turn into a hannah montana so i'm
going to choose identity key i'm just
saying you don't need magic to be hannah
montana you just need like talent or
something i mean well magic would make
it easier
the next question is pick a locking key
character to trust with a secret and the
options are duncan lock
ellie whedon scott cavendish rufus
whedon rendell lock or jackie vida
i don't know how he went all those years
without telling nina anything about me
and never trust a dead person well it's
the secret would be safe
but it's safe for him
wow that's a valid point though am i
like whispering it into the grave or
into the earth
yeah i'm going to go with ellie whedon i
think she's solid really i think she
hides a lot
exactly you tell her
she's she's going to hide it forever i'm
going to go with duncan i feel like he
like he's like a good dude i'm also
going to go duncan because duncan i just
he's so friendly and here is the final
question finally which netflix series
would you love to guest are on sex
education
squid game stranger things
outer banks never have i ever
or
you i'm gonna get patty here for a
second um i've already played comrade
griffin
[Laughter]
a little pettiness
i felt like buttoning up for this one
yeah i've auditioned for stranger things
four times and i haven't gotten anything
so um pardon me don't choose that just
get me on the show um the other part of
me is like nah you know what no
well i just worked with madison bailey
from outer banks and that set seems like
a lot of fun and she has nothing but
nice things to say about it so i'm
choosing outer banks although i would be
the
palest person to live in the bahamas
i just like last week finished watching
the new season of sex education and i
thought it was so unbelievably good the
asterisk on this is like as long as they
don't make me do a british accent if i
can be like an exchange student then i
absolutely would be on sex education
yeah i'm stuck between sex education and
stranger things well 111 million
households just watched squid game so
i'm gonna make it
111 and 1. 112.
i'm going to choose squid game i want to
be one of the guys that has maxi
[Music]
i am
the amazing kinsey lock
my god surprise
yes she
she's not guys she's not here but she's
here in spirit through me
my personality matches kinsey i'm
sincerely loyal and an introvert my
heart is always in the right place i can
be a bit impulsive but that's only
because i'm trying to protect those
closest to me total shock
let's go
your personality matches gabe you're
cunning ambitious and resourceful
like gabe you're someone who will do
anything to achieve their goals
literally anything your ambition is what
others gravitate towards you are a
planner who is constantly thinking ahead
and hoping others will catch up
i mean not sure about this i know that
gabe and i aren't the same person he's
just a character but i feel like weirdly
proud right now i got nina locke
oh my god wow
my personality matches nina you're
sympathetic affectionate and candid like
nina your family is the most important
thing in the world and you will do
almost anything to make sure they feel
safe and love you've overcome a lot in
your life and it has only made you
stronger i don't know how buzzfeed knows
all about
all about me we are some of the cast of
lock and key please watch our show it's
on netflix that's all i have to say and
thank you to buzzfeed for having us
i'm gonna keep doing it until i get bode
you